first comes love then comes marriage and  a lot of them are happening this weekend  here in Clark County over 1200 marriage  licenses have been awarded just since  Wednesday the marriage license bureau  says couples have waited in lines as  long as an hour and a half to get one  they say the surge comes from the  satisfying dates uh this weekend because  today 11 11 22 and tomorrow 11 12 22.  newlyweds we spoke to actually flew in  some of them from out of the country for  this day like this couple from Canada  it just feels right you know it's uh  it's numerical it matches up it's easy  to remember 11 11 22 you know it just  kind of rolls off the tongue like  Destiny said it's easy to remember and  you know something a little significant  for the date  Vegas weddings where they were married  this morning says they had 40  back-to-back ceremonies today they are  fully booked for tomorrow as well other  couples in downtown report having more  than 100 weddings planned per day